the golden knights have been busy the
last couple of hours making those final
last-minute trades getting their roster
set up for the upcoming season
and eight sports now anchor john treats
joining us now with more on the latest
john
that's right denise the golden knights
are shaking the roster like a stanley
cup wishing snow globe
we don't have those in las vegas they
have traded paul stasny to the jets in
exchange for defenseman carl dalstrom
in a draft pick this is the second time
in stasi's career that
he has been traded to winnipeg he was a
member of that 2018 team that lost to
vegas in the western conference final
the 34 year old center had 17 goals and
21 assists in 71 games for vegas this
past season
and added nine points the postseason
stasny has one season remaining on a
three-year deal here in vegas
and the deal was likely done to open up
salary cap space for vegas to
pursue blues defenseman alex petrangelo
who became a free agent
earlier today so they're still working
things now the golden knights
also announced they've resigned thomas
noshek and chandler stevenson
no word on marc-andre fleury but stay
tuned it will be a busy couple of days
thanks very much john we do